james  fate  draws us back together  now your enemy's my enemy  how did that happen well you live long  enough  harder to tell the good from bad  villains from heroes these days  we used to be able to get into a room  with the enemy now they're just floating  in the ether  she still loves you did you know that  what is it you don't know what this is  is she one of them  i don't know her at all  when her secret finds its way out  it'll be the death of you  james bond  we both eradicate people  to make the world a better place  i just want to be a little  tidier  i met your new double o  she's a disarming young woman  have you ever flown one of these things  before  nope  come on bond where the hell are you  if we don't do this  there will be nothing left to say  when you're ready you're late  can i just have one nice evening please  before the world explodes  [Music]  you